[Music]
McDonald's CEO Steve Easterbrook has
been fired for a consensual relationship
with a colleague the man responsible for
doubling the fast-food giant share price
violated the company's no-dating policy
but surely company shouldn't be allowed
to dictate whom employees can and can't
date it's a violation of their human
rights if the relationship is consensual
if there's no abuse of power if it
doesn't affect the work why the hell not
or when oppose me - world has the
pendulum swung too far against male
bosses and surely this is anti-feminist
next companies will be telling women if
and when they can have babies
McDonald's employs two hundred and ten
thousand people many of them young
sparks will inevitably flag given the
amount of time we all spend at work
these days it's probably one of the best
and safest ways to meet people safe
because unlike dating apps you get to
save people up close before you date
them
McDonald's needs to start treating
employees like grown-ups
for being to each other I've been in a
situation once upon a time not anymore
where I've been in a relationship with a
work colleague
but the relationship began before we
worked together and then somebody in my
company hired the former partner while I
was abroad because I had said no because
I was worried about precisely this thing
but actually I agree with you I think we
need to make a distinction between
hierarchies where the direct line
manager you know such as in my case with
you because I'm your boss shouldn't be
allowed to be in a relationship but if
they're equal zero company I mean I know
in LBC there's been some wonderful
romances
[Laughter]
no pressure from anyone I've been the
problem with this is in terms of the
disparity between the levels from what
we understand that it was a subordinate
that he had a relationship with and I
think the problem with these things is
what I would say Carol is the problem is
often it's the woman that is the
subordinate and often if somebody is
actually going to be worse off in the
scenario it is the woman there's a
statistic to show that 42% of women who
have relationships with their line
managers feel that they are negatively
affected them with their college there
are some girls for whom power I agree
with June but for a different reason
I agree that his position is relevant
but the point is he is the global CEO of
McDonald's you are the CEO of a company
that has a policy it's quite an extreme
policy and I'm not saying everyone
should have I also think there is some
context McDonald's has been plagued by
thousands and allegations of harassment
not consensual romance but harassment
and I can see why in that context it is
a company that sorry why she killed
this is what McDonald's say Steve
Easterbrook is separated from the
company following the board's
determination that he violated company
policy and demonstrated poor judgment
involving a recent consensual
relationship with an employee they go on
there's absolutely no place for
harassment or discrimination of any kind
in society or at McDonald's we have
long-standing policies procedures and
training in place specifically designed
to prevent sexual harassment we
regularly review and evolve these and
we've recently rolled out a new training
program and guidance we take any
allegations extremely seriously you know
I think I've been separated from a few
jobs it's a suspicion this policy is
more about protecting their corporate
reputations and saving money on legal
bills than it is in creating a safe
workplace because of this presumption
that's right if it's in your contract
even if you're the chief there is a
particular spot I've actually turned up
to work when you're in the workplace you
get to know if they're decent people if
they're good I would like to know how
long he was dating this girl for and
perhaps that he could have changed the
policy once he knew he was attractive
company violated his own employee level
following it yourself I mean like do you
think it's an interesting area because
would you institute a policy though so
you set up a massively looking for you I
think everything I would want to create
a culture where there are very clear
rules about respectful behavior but if
people do form consensual relationships
but I would have an issue if it's
people's direct yeah he made a mistake
so he says I engaged in recent
consensual relationship with an employee
which violated McDonald's policy this
was a mistake
given the values of the company I agree
with the board that it's time for me to
move on he may well of course been
regretting that because let's bear in
mind this is the man who reworked the
British side he then got the global CEO
I think he's probably a very committed
individual he's probably really hurting
he's not he started off as a branch
manager then he was running the whole
shebang I don't agree with much that
Michael O'Leary says his bosses Ryan
Evans just look at what he says here I
really get very worried when companies
start having policy on you know people's
private activities if it's consensual
between consenting adults Godspeed
I think you know companies should have
company policies that affect you know
corporate behavior but trying to impose
policies on what consenting adults do
between themselves I think is a step too
far come on what are you gonna do I just
think you can't you can't tell me